This is an interesting media story.
If you've been watching the White House coronavirus
press briefings, you might have noticed that
there's a particular seat in the back left
of the room left.
If you're looking from the lectern where Trump
stands, which has frequently been sort of
like the lunatic media seat.
Oftentimes there's a reporter from this wacky
right wing media outlet away and that sits
there one.
TIME Trump's former press secretary, Sean
Spicer was sitting there and we've circled
that seat in red in the image that we're showing
our TV and video audience.
The questions from that seat are typically
just ridiculous, sycophantic Trump softball
questions.
But yesterday there wasn't someone from o.n.
in that seat.
And it seems that because of social distancing,
fewer seats are being filled during these
press briefings.
But somehow at one point, this wacky away
and reporter Chanel reon asked the question
anyway.
And she didn't have a seat.
She was seen standing during the press briefing.
So we realized she was standing at the back
of the room.
We flagged her with a green arrow.
In this next image.
And she asked the question.
And it was sort of weird that like everybody
has a seat except she's standing in the back
and looks very kind of disheveled.
That was really weird.
Well, the White House Correspondents Association
has decided to kick out away from the press
room altogether.
They've removed their seat and issued a statement
saying, as you're all aware, the White House
Correspondents Association issued a policy
last month, last month restricting seating
in the room to comply with CDC guidelines.
We've asked reporters without a seat, essentially
don't come to the briefings we are writing
to inform you that the White House Correspondents
Association board has voted to remove a news
outlet from the rotation because a reporter
twice attended briefings in contravention
of this policy.
Now, of course, they will argue this is politically
motivated.
All of this other stuff.
But they are the only ones showing up even
when they don't have a seat.
And yelling, softball, sycophantic lunatic
questions while standing at the back of the
room.
Check out some of the insane questions asked
by people in that seat.
Do you consider the term show a very good
way to treat?
We've heard the term Chinese racist.
It's food that originates in China.
It has.
No, I don't think it's racist.
I don't think it's racist at all.
On that note, major left wing news media have
teamed up with Chinese Communist Party Eric.
And your reasons for making these claims about
China's rise isn't alarming.
Major media players just hope you are consistently
siding with foreign state propaganda, Islamic
radicals and and cartels house.
And he works right here at the White House
with direct access to you and your team.
It amazes me when I read the things that I
read.
She can barely get the question out.
And of course, these are loony cuckoo for
Cocoa Puffs.
Questions.
Here's another one where they insert abortion
and try to compare.
This was Sunday, I think.
Try to equate in some way death from the virus
spreading virally to death from legal medical
procedure, abortion, which, of course, most
Americans don't even believe death is an accurate
characterization of.
Here's the questions.
Sunday in thousand four hundred and five Americans
have died from trying a virus in the last
60 days.
Meanwhile, you have two thousand three hundred
and sixty nine children who are killed by
their mothers through elective abortions each
day.
That's sixteen and a half thousand children
killed every week.
Two states have suspended elective abortions
to make more resources available for coronavirus
cases.
That's Texas and Ohio.
Do you agree with states who are placing kind
of virus victims above elective abortions?
And should more states be doing the same?
Well, I think all we're doing is we're trying
to as a group governors and as Republicans
and Democrats, we're just working together
to solve this problem.
Hilariously, that one was actually too crazy
even for Trump to take the bait on, like when
Trump finds the sycophantic suck up questions
to wacky to even take seriously.
You know that you're doing something wrong.
So this is actually great news.
Unfortunately, you know.
Oh, and shouldn't have a seat.
Period.
The fact that they had to lose it by violating
social distancing measures.
Okay.
They are worse than Fox News.
They can't follow simple rules.
So they're out.
But again, they could simply force their way
back into the room.
They've been showing up uninvited anyway without
even having a seat.
So really strange times in which we are living
and away.
And and and remember that Trump has been sort
of praising 0a and for a while now.
And he seems gleeful when he calls on 0a and
and often calls on them by names as.
Yes, okay.
And beautiful question.
Even Trump has not taken the bait on some
of their wacky delusional questions.
This is a win, although for the wrong reasons
they should be kicked out because they aren't
a serious news outlet.
Instead, they're being kicked out because
they're showing up in.
The ending and the back to your questions.
Even when they don't actually have an assigned
seat, you'll take any winds that will take
the winds no matter how we can get home, I
guess, is my view